jacques prévert est mort le poète s'est
éteint à l'âge de 77 ans l'aide
logistique français au zaïre la gauche
désapprouve santiago carillo y la
légalisation du pce un pas en avant vers
la démocratie
plus de deux cent cinquante mille
étrangers à paris ce week-end des
touristes mais aussi des devises 25e
rallye safari automobile victoire de val
de gartempe cellius mesdames messieurs
bonsoir jacques prévert est mort cet
après-midi dans sa propriété de menville
la petite dans la manche il est mort à
77 ans des suites d'un cancer du poumon
comment ne pas être ému de cette
disparition jacques prévert était très
connue très aimé et le plus célèbre des
poètes contemporains
sa poésie est populaire dans le sens le
plus noble poésie que l'on chante dans
la rue ou dans le métro sur des airs de
cosma poésie qu'on le retrouve au cinéma
dans les films de marcel carné dont il
était le dialoguiste jacques prévert
était aussi auteur de théâtre et conteur
il a écrit notamment de nombreux livres
pour enfants et puis au cours des
dernières années de sa vie il s'était
consacré de plus en plus à sa passion de
toujours
les collages toujours des trouvailles
une manière désinvolte et ironique et
l'amour des petites choses de la vie
le quotidien non conformiste jacques
prévert sera inhumé jeudi matin dans le
petit cimetière de la commune de
montville
dix jours avant le sommet franco
africain de dakar la france est donc
intervenu de manière indirecte dans le
conflit zaïrois depuis samedi 11 gros
porteurs de l'armée de l'air des
transall et un dc-8 achemine vers le
zaïre les moyens militaires que le roi
hassan ii du maroc a accepté d'accorder
au président mobutu à paris on souligne
qu'aucun militaire net engagés dans
cette opération
le pont aérien a été décidé conformément
aux accords de défense franco zaïrois le
gouvernement aille roi pour sa part a
fait savoir aujourd'hui que les avions
français n'allaient pas au combat mais
qu'ils étaient utilisés pour transporter
les troupes marocaines jusqu'à kinshasa
c'est le président mobutu qui avait
demandé aux pays africains par
l'intermédiaire de l'eau l'ua de lui
accorder son aide pour lutter contre les
ex gendarme quête anglais venus d'angola
et qui se sont infiltrés dans la riche
région minière de chabat une région qui
est l'élément moteur de toute l'économie
zaïroise le président mobutu accusé
l'angola d'être à l'origine de cette
infiltration et à travers l'angola
l'union soviétique et cuba l'angola
rejette l'accusation et répond qu'il
s'agit d'une affaire interne au zaïre
une partie des pays africains inquiet de
la pénétration ce ghetto cubaine a donc
décidé de venir en aide au zaïre le
maroc mais aussi l'egypte bien qu'il n'y
ait pas encore eu d'envoi de troupes
égyptiennes et le soudan
pékin s'est également rangée dans le
camp varois la france est la seule des
nations occidentales à s'être engagée à
washington le président carter a
totalement rejeté aujourd'hui l'idée
d'une entreprise concertée franco
américaine les états unis sont étrangers
à la décision française
mais jimmy carter a souligné la gravité
de la situation la médiation du nigeria
est d'importance critique at il dit les
réactions en france roger chinaud
président du groupe républicain
indépendant l'assemblée nationale il me
paraît normal que la france apporte son
soutien à un effort de collaboration
interafricaine ayant pour objectif la
sauvegarde de l'indépendance du zaïre
maurice couve de murville la députée rpr
il s'agit d'apporter la démonstration
que la france s'oppose à la subversion
en afrique avec l'idée en arrière-plan
de rassurer les pays francophones
claude estier porte-parole du parti
socialiste l'intervention française a
été faite sans consultation du parlement
ni même du gouvernement et puis
réactions très vives de robert ballanger
président du groupe communiste à
l'assemblée il a écrit une lettre au
président de la république une lettre où
il se déclare indigné et demandent un
débat avec vote au parlement
il ya une volonté d'ingérence dans la
politique intérieure de ce pays
une prise de position en faveur d'une
telle qu'en danse ce qui nous font
encore compromet gravement pour demain
les relations de coopération de la
france avec tous les pays d'afrique mais
qui en plus peut entraîner dès
maintenant des difficultés considérables
et peut-être même nous entraîner plus
loin et nous le pensons aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d' aide que ben forcément plus
allons il n'y a pas de réoccuper de
celui tic donc battre réaction n'est pas
une réaction plus politique non c'est
une réaction pour les intérêts de notre
pays
le calme est revenu au pays basque où
trente mille manifestants ont réclamé
hier la légalisation du peuple de ce
qu'a dit à l'occasion de sa fête
nationale manifestation interdite par
les autorités des affrontements ont fait
plusieurs blessés à vitoria et d'urango
mais l'événement majeur de ce week-end
en espagne reste la légalisation du pce
qui sera fêté le 17 avril prochain à
madrid
le point de vue de santiago carillo sur
la décision du gouvernement espagnol
vous savez je pense que soit l'aide est
un anticommuniste intelligent c'est à
dire un homme qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
ne peut pas détruire les idées avec la
répression avec l'illégalisation qu'il
faut combattre les idées par des moyens
politiques et je pense qu'il a choisi de
combattre les communistes pas seulement
les communistes les tendances de gauche
par des moyens politiques or
reconnaissant par exemple à une
existence légale à nous y rendre et
connaissant notre assistance légale
c'est-à-dire pour nous combattre sur le
terrain décide et il faut le reconnaître
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant nous allons travailler comme
en partie légale nous allons commencer
notre campagne électorale j espère que
la légalité sera suivi d véritable
liberté pour propres roe paris propose
notre programme pour faire nos activités
politiques
nous souhaitons ça aussi pour tous les
autres partis politiques mais et compris
ceux qui ne sont pas encore les lycées
qui doivent l'être
est ce que vous allez faire pression
pour essayer qu'il le soit nous allons
faire pression mais j'espère que dans
cette position nous serons ensemble tous
les forces démocratiques espagnoles
les présidents des groupes
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat seront reçus demain à 17h30
palais de l'elysée par le président
giscard d'estaing le chef de l'état qui
a passé quelques jours dans son château
d'eau ton dans le loir et cher a
participé aujourd'hui à un méchoui
organisé par une cinquantaine de
rapatrier dans une ferme voisine
à cette occasion le président de la
république a annoncé que les problèmes
concernant les harkis et les français
rapatriés d'algérie allait être recenser
et étudier avant cet automne afin d'être
résolue attentats à l'explosif la nuit
dernière sur l'autoroute a9 à narbonne 6
cabines de péage ont été détruites par
une trentaine d'hommes armés et masqués
ce coup de force vient d'être
revendiquée dans une communication
téléphonique à notre station de fr3
toulouse par un interlocuteur déclarant
appartenir au comité d'action contre les
corridas
ce comité interdite en france depuis
septembre tout corrida de sanglantes
d'autres représailles pour être
intervenir
monsieur françois mitterrand rendrait
visite au président américain jimmy
carter à l'automne prochain
cette information est apportée par
l'hebdomadaire newsweek qui affirme que
la visite du cada général du ps serait
un triomphe pour les socialistes
français fin des vacances pascales les
retours ont été ce qui était prévu
particulièrement difficile en ce qui les
concerne les parisiens vont retrouver
une capitale littéralement assiégé par
les touristes
le temps ne les aura pas découragé le
froid la neige le vent et la pluie n'ont
pas dérouter les candidats au tourisme
on estime déjà à plus de 250 mille le
nombre d'étrangers qui ont envahi la
capitale pour le week-end pascal dont
plus de 75000 allemand et l'on ne compte
plus les sujets de sa majesté
on ne s'en plaint pas les devises le yen
est ce qu dos de la remarque et livres
arrivent par cars entiers il ne faut pas
l'oublier
le tourisme est l'une des premières
activités économiques de notre pays
en 1976 les recettes se montait à 13
milliards de francs soit au total 13
millions quatre cent soixante dix mille
visiteurs
quand ils arrivent par le train ils
rapportent annuellement à la sncf 500
millions de francs s'ils arrivent par
avion c'est un bénéfice de 1 milliard
800 millions ou celles utiles 9 à 10%
dans les hôtels de luxe 9 % dans les
trois étoiles les autres nos proches
voisins venus comme en balade cherche le
petit hôtel où le logement chez
l'habitant
ceux qui dépensent le plus les
américains environ 300 francs par jour
et par personne
ceux qui dépensent le mois les
hollandais 100 francs par jour et ce
qu'ils dépensent encore mois les
français lorsqu'ils se rendent à
l'étranger
ils viennent donc chercher chez nous ce
qu'ils pourraient trouver chez eux sans
nul doute mais avec ce petit quelque
chose en plus qui est bien français
l'agneau prés salés de la baie du mont
saint michel c'est un délice réservé à
quelques gastronomes ainsi un millier de
personnes environ ont pu déguster en
cette période de pâques ces petits
oignons une saveur particulière parce
que leur maire ps toute l'année sur des
herbus régulièrement recouvert par la
mer
chaque année dix mille agneaux pressel
et du mont saint michel sont vendus sur
le marché et les producteurs une
cinquantaine en tout n'arrive pas à
satisfaire la demande car bien entendu
la surface des herbus n'est pas
extensible
ils s'étendent sur trois mille hectares
environ voici comment se pratique cet
élevage dans le val saint père en
reportage de fr3 rennes
pour les éleveurs de moutons de la baie
du mont saint michel la merveille de la
région c'est les rebuts une herbe qui
pousse sur les grèves doté de qualités
nutritives particulière parce que la
marée l'enrichît au moins une fois par
mois de sel marin il ya 400 hectares des
rebuts dans la baie et 8000 brebis il
pèse chaque jour en toute liberté
depuis février les agneaux nés à noël
gonfle le troupeau et se nourrissent
également de cet airbus ce sont les prés
salés du mont saint michel
c'est un ennemi on aura peut-être moins
sur le marché en effet certains éleveurs
ceux du bas courty par exemple ont
enregistré jusqu'à 30 % de mortalité au
moment de l'agnelage pendant la
sécheresse beaucoup de brebis ont
souffert de décalcification plusieurs
agneaux sont mort-nés cet échec accroît
l'inquiétude des trente deux éleveurs de
ce secteur déjà empoisonné par les
conséquences de l'ensablement de la baie
les herbus presse à l'élever du mont
saint michel ne sont plus les mêmes que
ceux d'il ya vingt ans c'est à dire que
depuis quelques années les la baie du
mont saint michel les sables remonte
effectivement à une rapidité
fondamentale est alors plus les grèves
montrent moins démarrer et accèdent et
pour avoir les herbus prayssas et du
mont saint michel les marais couvraient
autrefois régulièrement tous les mois et
on ne voit maintenant que démarrer à
partir de 110 degrés 100-112 la valeur
nutritive des airbus le revenu la valeur
nutritive est moins puissante -
effective que il ya une vingtaine
d'années en plus les effectifs ont
légèrement augmenté mais les grèves de
la baie du mont saint michel ne
produisent plus secrets produisent et
elles ne peuvent plus subvenir à une
quantité de boutons comme il ya
évidemment la production du pré salé
naturel et l'ong comporte des risques et
coûte plus cher
ces éleveurs du facteur qui ont une
faible productivité surtout par rapport
aux éleveurs des polders
les fermes de beauvoir en effet
pratiquer un élevage intensif 250 brebis
en moyenne par troupeaux des agneaux 200
jours qui ne cuisine jamais les herbus
mais les rendements sont plus élevés
un agneau si stephen chez les éleveurs
traditionnels les maires ils vont
marcher sur les abus et les agneaux et
bois le lait de la mère mais ça ne
malgré tout ça n'est pas du frais prés
salés les frais très sale et les agneaux
qui sont avec les maires les herbus mais
à mon idée ça donnait moindre qualité
mais plus savoure mais faut autant que
possible bien nourrir ou attendre le
temps c'est à bien tout seul vous pouvez
faire un bon agneaux en trois mois
en nourrissant effet vous voulez laisser
faire la nature est fausse
on dit que les éleveurs assez importants
font disparaître les petits éleveurs
c'est vrai charge elle n'y croit pas du
tout aucun label ne garantit le pré salé
du mont saint michel
de ce fait ceux qui perpétuent la
méthode de l'élevage traditionnel sont
plus ou moins les et pourtant c'était
bien l'ambition des vingt-sept éleveurs
du val-saint-père lorsqu'ils ont
constitué leur syndic en 1972 mais leurs
objectifs sont demeurés limité aux
traitements collectif des maladies et
une meilleure sélection des béliers
aujourd'hui il se contente de lutter
pour le maintien de l'élevage dans leur
secteur
car un autre souci extérieurs à la
profession les préoccupent qui en eau
des éleveurs qui disparaissent du loc'h
peut-être et puis il ya eu vraiment des
des embêtements de touristes surtout des
clubs hippiques qui bouscule les troupes
et les gens nous marrer abandonne petit
à petit je crois que c'est là qu'est
quelques problèmes tout de suite pour
nous étant donné que étant donné que si
les les gens s'en vont petit à petit il
y aura plus de moutons sur les graines
et le verbe envahira et cassiman trois
sachets pas
ensablement tourisme élevages intensifs
la légende du prés salés du
mont-saint-michel s'estompe
toutefois la clientèle locale et trouve
encore chanson auprès des éleveurs
qu'elle connaît bien
mais il est certain que l'élevage a
atteint son développement maximum il
reste à le préserver autant que le
patrimoine du monde
football la bulgarie remporte le 26e
festival international du junior de
cannes
la france comme année dernière échoue en
finale 1 but à 0 football encore coup
dur pour saint-etienne qui a deux jours
des huitièmes de finale de la coupe de
france perd deux de ses joueurs
synaeghel et farizon blessés ne pourront
s'aligner mercredi soir avec les verts
face à roye cyclisme troisième étape du
tour de belgique victoire du holland et
jose schipper le belge walter planckaert
conserve la première place
il est à dire c'est aujourd'hui à
longchamp ordre d'arrivée le 4 le 19 le
14 les rapports dans l'ordre pour 5
francs 4272 50 dans un ordre différent
toujours pour 5 francs 850 4,50 sport
automobile suédois waldegard de sueur
escorte 1800 remporte le 25e safari
rally une épreuve particulièrement
sélective cette année les african safari
ou safari rally automobile a été comme
les années précédentes marquées par un
parcours difficile sur les routes de
kenya l'eau et la boue ont été les
caractéristiques du début de l'épreuve
mais à la fin dont nous voyons ici les
images
les voitures ont trouvé des routes
sèches sur lesquels leur passage dégagé
d'importants nuages de poussière la
victoire est revenue au suédois
waldegard ici avec la voiture numéro un
le suédois second en 74 et 3e en 75,1
pratiquement mené ce rallye de bout en
bout toujours donné trois premiers
jusqu'à qui s'est muée balle de garde
prenez la tête à 900 km de nairobi
le suédois n'a pas considéré ce rallye
comme difficile notre travail de
reconnaissance avec mon navigateur
en ce temps et lui c'était très
important et a déclaré balle de garder
nous a permis de repérer les endroits où
sous l'eau il y avait de la terre dure
ou de la thermale
quant aux organisateurs qui ont trouvé
ce parcours facile il y a tout de même
eu 68 voitures au départ est une dizaine
à l'arrivée
oh
de l'ouest et du nord-ouest de la france
au pays basque que le temps sera plus
doux mais couvert avec des plus et passe
dans le nord-est et l'est il sera très
nuageux avec des averses de pluie et des
neiges entre ces deux zones le temps
sera frais et nuageux tandis que dans
les régions méditerranéennes
les éclaircies prédomineront mais avec
des vents forts de nord-ouest
l'aboutissement se poursuivra sur la
moitié ouest du pays la zone faiblement
pluvieuse gagnera les régions allant des
vosges au golfe du lion neige au dessus
de 1000 mètres tandis que des éclaircies
se développeront sur le bassin aquitain
la vague de froid qui s'est abattue ce
week-end sur la france a fait deux
victimes deux randonneurs qui sont morts
de froid et d'épuisement dans les
pyrénées-orientales dans les halles
c'est une coulée de neige qui a provoqué
la mort du frère de gunter sachs
ernst sachs homme d'affaires domicilié à
genève a été emporté par une coulée de
neige dans le massif de la vanoise alors
qu'il skiait hors piste avec deux
moniteurs à la réunion deux nouvelles
failles se sont ouvertes aujourd'hui sur
le volcan de la fournaise de l'une de
ces failles s'échappent des gaz et de
l'autre de la lawe liquide
certains habitants de piton sainte-rose
qui avaient été autorisés à regagner
leur domicile ont dû à nouveau quitter
le village
regardez maintenant ce match de football
ce n'est pas un match de football comme
les autres ce la rencontre afrique du
sud rhodésie qui vient de se disputer à
johannesbourg l'événement d'ailleurs se
passe autant sur les gradins que sur le
stade
en effet pour la première fois en
afrique du sud le public n'avait pas été
séparés par des critères raciaux les
équipes elle même était intégré puisque
selon la nouvelle politique sportive
sud-africaine des noirs peuvent être
sélectionnés mais uniquement dans des
rencontres internationales 40000
spectateurs de toutes races ont assisté
à cette rencontre il y avait aussi un
fort contingent de policiers
mais ce ces policiers n'ont pas eu à
intervenir
la situation l'afrique australe
peut-elle se débloquer le secrétaire
britannique au foreign office david owen
est reparti en mission pour tenter
d'ouvrir la voie à un règlement négocié
dans le conflit rhodésien première étape
de monsieur owen la tanzanie où il est
arrivé aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle
mission de longue haleine
selon elle se termine passé une très
bonne nuit voici le rappel des titres
jacques prévert est mort le poète s'est
éteint à l'âge de 77 ans les deux
françaises aux haïr les communistes
demandent un débat à l'assemblée
nationale fin des vacances pascales 5
millions de français sur les routes du
retour demain soir entretien télévisé du
chef de l'état un thème la politique
étrangère